whoo so relative to everyone else who's
had videos out about the premiere of the
new ducktales I am late to this party
but I liked so much I want to talk about
it anyway so here we go so I I haven't
really talked about ducktales that much
I I would watch the show on occasion I
did have on VHS the ducktales movie
which I loved like still to this day
really love feel that it's it's a shame
that it's not as well remember it has
the show seems to be it doesn't come up
in conversations about Disney movies all
that often I find that especially
annoying given how much of the plot
details the Latin Aladdin would later
lift from it but I like ducktales a lot
and and of course I played the video
game on the original Nintendo beat the
crap out of it why ducktales remastered
for my ps3 beat the crap out of that too
so I like ducktales a lot and there is
almost nothing I don't like about this
new version first of all love the theme
they switched up just enough but it
feels just enough like the originally I
just love that being a Doctor Who fan
David Tennant as Scrooge McDuck how can
I not love that I really like that they
have found a way to distinguish Huey
Dewey and Louie I can't
I actually know which ones which this
time I could never remember which ones
which I actually known how human read do
iam blue Lou in green I now know because
they did little things beyond just the
colors to make them look different
they've got different personalities now
and yet still feel true to the boys
overall because do you still see the
aspects that that were always present
but they've kind of spaced them out and
then emphasized those aspects greater in
each individual one rather than copy and
paste the same character in just palette
swap it so you've got three
there were lots of little nos of the
original I love the marbles joke so if
you watch the original the boys were
always using marbles in these weird
crazy ways to get out of jams or
whatever and he's got this bag of
marbles like I've got an idea he's just
using it to beat on a tour hop until I
get oh that was great the the jokes are
pretty rapid-fire it did take me a
little bit to sort of get into the pace
of this thing which as far as Jojo is
pretty rapid pace and that's pretty
standard for animation these days
whether it is film or television it's
pretty rapid-fire and once I got into
the pace it works pretty well I think
this is gonna be a weird nitpick
something about the animation style
makes Donald Duck harder for me to
understand I know that sounds weird I
think it's just because of how basic the
lip movements are with the stylized look
that they're going for which is look I
like overall but that those movements
are so basic I don't without a ton of
articulation in his bill I found it
harder to understand Donald Duck than
usual normally I am able to follow him a
lot easier
I love the changes to webby because she
if there was some dead weight in the
original duck tails it was webby I mean
they did what they could for her as time
went on but overall she was just she was
annoying and the characters were always
annoyed with her and they and the
characters you'd liked were always
annoyed with her so you couldn't help
but find her annoying but they found a
neat way to sort of turn that around
without just having her be
you know the tomboy who does all the
stuff better like she's obviously really
enthusiastic but she's also you know
clearly a little bit awkward and she's
got a lot of knowledge but she still
makes mistakes like the fact that she
mistook a garage for like a secret
Museum so I mean I like that stuff mrs.
Beakley is an interesting to us I'm I'm
kind of liking how annoyed she gets with
when Scrooge isn't basically telling her
to take a memo she's like I'm not your
secretary so that was all good glum gold
that was a lot of fun Craig Ferguson did
a great job voicing him and I liked the
the
that got pulled along for that and in
this sort of it really is two episodes
you can kind of break it up but the and
I love the the just these adventuring
spirit abut which is exactly what you
want a lot of duck tales out of Scrooge
stories is that adventure and that going
out into the unknown getting the
treasure coming up against crazy wild
things and I love that
Scrooge can be completely nonplussed by
some of it like very unimpressed by like
the pirate with the sword on the
headless man horse and it says I want
the head of scrooge mcduck he just goes
we just saw the first hatch so I love
how notch on it can be about that yet
still recognize when things are bad
because you there's a much higher degree
of sort of oh crap when like the dragon
comes out and stuff like that and I'm
also I'm gonna be curious to see how
much of a serialized story this tells I
don't expect it to be a long-form thing
but I am finding it interesting that it
seems to be leaning towards I again it's
early but it seems to be leaning towards
developing relationships between the
characters that will continue to grow
and evolve I mean we're already seeing
that specifically with the highlighted
sections we see between Dewey and
Scrooge so we're seeing some some signs
of that so I don't really want
serialized storytelling in the sense of
let's tell this story overall these
episodes know I want little I
self-contained adventures but if the
dynamics between the characters it can
continue to evolve as the show goes on
and I'll have a lot of fun with that
pretty much the only character didn't
get some sort of adjustment in terms of
their behavior or their relationship to
the other characters seems to be
launchpad who's pretty much the same guy
which is fine I am absolutely on board
for that because Launchpad in the
correct doses which they have him dosed
very well and in this premiere pair of
episodes in the correct dosage he's just
awesome and wonderful and lovable and
he's all that here and I also gotta say
I got my daughter to watch this and she
had seen the DuckTales moment she liked
it well enough but I got her to watch
this and her first question was do we
have any more episodes in which I had to
go no we're gonna have to wait a week
sweetie so I you know I consider that to
be a ringing endorsement because
normally she doesn't go for anything
that doesn't feature dogs or wolves in
it so that that's that's a big thumbs up
from I would say maybe it's slightly
younger than the target demographic but
you know what I'm I'm happy to see the
show back I think the attitude with
which they're approaching it works I
think the style with which they are
approaching it both visually and in
terms of the humor and the
characterization all works and it is
different enough that it feels like it's
worth engaging in but true enough to the
original that it does not feel like
they're changing it just because they
can it feel every change every choice
feels like it was made for a reason and
that is the exact correct way to reboot
a beloved property so DuckTales the new
series have you seen it the premiere
episode at any rate what did you think
about it whatever you thought drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half of
the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]